hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Luke Cage ending season 2 video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the series yet if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything I do Marvel videos every week
click that Bell to enable alerts so
maybe you finished iron fist and you
have like a couple big questions is
there going to be a season two given all
the negative reactions that it's had all
the things that it seems like they need
to fix before they can actually do it
they just finished wrapping defenders
and Finn Jones posted this picture like
I've been working on this for the past
year so literally he shot all of iron
fists then rolled straight into
defenders shot eight episodes of that
and now he's done so he's going to take
this big long break go hibernate for a
while and they're going to figure out
what's going on with season two yes
there will be a season two that's just
the way the Netflix shows work each of
the individual shows regardless of team
ups will get future seasons daredevil is
just the marquee show that everybody
loves so they're going to roll that out
first so there is like a pecking order
to all these shows so some will get
their next season before others but
there were just a couple key things that
happened at the very end of iron fist
that tee up events that they'll directly
address in season two so they didn't
it'd be a major middle finger there's
just so many things from the comics that
they teed up everybody's wondering if
they're going to do a Heroes for Hire
style team-up I'll address that too but
the biggest things first Danny and
Colleen wings show up at the gates of
Kunlun and find all these dead massacred
hand soldiers in Kunlun isn't there it
hasn't been a full year so they should
be able to get back in
dawn
and we're
I should have been here
oh my mode
in the context of the show there are
seven capital cities of heaven that
slowly move into alignment with earth
allowing people to get into each
different city Kunlun was in alignment
with earth this year
that's how Danny ran came back the thing
is is when they show up it should still
be there so something happened to shift
the alignment of the celestial clock now
that could be something that the steel
Serpent Davos did with Madame Gao
because it looked like the hand tried to
force their way in Madame Gao said that
she had been to Kunlun before even if
she wasn't born there so presumably this
was her faction trying to force their
way in they were fought off but in the
chaos someone was able to shift the
alignment so Kunlun is now inaccessible
to Danny ran there's some really cool
backdoors they have in the comic book
and ways of getting around the issue of
it being in alignment with earth but I
don't think they're going to jump
straight to that and even though Madame
Gao seems like the culprit here in Davos
seems like he's working with Madame Gao
I don't necessarily blame him for what
happened here but either way Danny Rand
is stuck on earth so this explains how
he winds up with the defenders jumping
to join each imploding with Davos so
there are two different agendas going on
here joy Meacham is very clearly being
set up as the villain for season two
like somebody who started out as a
friend and was twisted by events to
believe something that's not true Danny
Rand is the reason that my life fell
apart
Davos believes the same thing but he
wants the power of the iron fist for
himself so he's going to try and kill
Danny and steal that the actor teased
that he is nowhere in defenders so they
would have to wait two Iron Fist season
two to address that and I'm not
expecting joy Meacham to show up during
defenders either they're just already so
many characters in that series for the
most part the Davos character in the
comics has already become the steel
Serpent when we see him he already has
that power
like he tries to steal the power from
the Dragon before it's his time he
almost dies but then in an alliance
later with crane mother the leader of
one of the other capital cities of
heaven he gets a version of Iron Fist
powers through her but instead of
harnessing his own she he steals Chi
from other people so he is going to try
and steal Danny Rance Chi so it's a bit
of a change from the comic book so what
bakudo he very clearly escaped it seems
like they're going to resurrect him
he'll come back but he teased that
someone above him in his organization
the hand was very eager to work with the
iron fist so a big theme of iron fist
was people coming back from the dead I
think this is a teaser for Elektra in
defenders because remember even without
all the hand stuff that she's involved
in she's a very rich person very
powerful so because it's been so long
since daredevil season 2 ended it sounds
like she's already come back and is
doing something that we'll find out
about in defenders so if you wonder what
all that weird Harold Meacham stuff the
back half of the season was that just
totally felt out of tone for the rest of
the series and just wandering around
like Frankenstein he used the name
Frankenstein on his phone then literally
started acting like Frankenstein for the
last half of the season it was crazy
that's just meant to tee up Elektra
coming back the idea that each time
someone dies and comes back they get a
little crazier each time but they do
keep coming back and speaking of Meechum
so Ward Meacham ends the series taking
true control of R and in partnership
with Danny
he seems like you kind of in a healthy
place he's going to have a lot of
problems in season two but he's a good
person
and he'll wind up being the jeryn
hogarth from the comics so jeryn hogarth
in the series is a woman played by
carrie anne moss who is an attorney that
works for Danny ran but in the comic
books jeryn hogarth is the business
partner that runs rand enterprises
day-to-day for Danny ran while he's out
busy being iron fist
what about Heroes for Hire the thing
that everybody was I do think that it
would have been smarter for them to just
do Heroes for Hire rather than try to do
an iron fist solo series because one of
the strongest things about daredevil
season 2 were those other characters
[Music]
around ready
Punisher was such a good character in
performance that he got his own solo
series after they saw that footage
they're like we are giving you your own
TV show and none of the other characters
and iron fists were strong enough to
merit that so what will probably happen
is is they will do a season two but what
you'll see is more crossing over so we
have Iron Man that's going to be in a
spider-man movie Luke Cage was a huge
part of Jessica Jones season one so I
think that you will see Luke Cage iron
fist stuff happening even though each of
the Netflix shows will get their own
seasons like there will be no true
Heroes for Hire TV show you'll just see
a really big story arc on iron fist and
on Luke Cage involving that other
character the only reason I think
they'll do it that way is because of the
way all these contracts work out so when
they first said that they were going to
do Marvel Netflix series they contracted
to do series for each of the four
separate characters then a defenders
team-up there wasn't a lot of room for
doing different types of shows like a
Heroes for Hire show but that could
always change in the future
they didn't originally plan to do a
Punisher solo series and they added that
to the roster so they can do that they
can totally change the paradigm and just
combine two of the shows into one show
and do Heroes for Hire but as the dust
settles what's probably going to happen
next year is you'll see daredevil season
3 Jessica Jones season 2 and Luke Cage
season 2 I think you'll definitely see
him pop up on those other shows but an
actual iron fist season 2 probably won't
show up till 2019 it'll give them enough
time to train the actors to do the right
types of fight sequences and find the
right story and I really do want to see
Orson Randall and for those of you
asking this 1948 iron fist yes that is
supposed to be Orson Randall so he was a
bit of a deep cut Easter egg on the show
I know everybody's wondering about the
comic book costume is he ever going to
wear that thin Jones said that they're
working up to that but it's probably not
going to happen right away which is kind
of disappointing but they could always
change their mind about that you never
really can trust what the actors say
about the TV show because the Marvel
Gestapo are just sitting waiting to pick
them off if they say something that's
spoilery so yes there will be a comic
book costume but it might not happen for
a while congratulations to ray ray or
the latest Marvel giveaway winner be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel it was a new round
that started in this video on ounce the
winner
the next time I post a marble video what
you went to that click here for my
non-spoilery Power Rangers review very
nostalgic and you can click here for my
Iron Fist review thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys tonight